[Music]
oh no what's he doing here that guy's
also hey everybody I was going it is
April 3rd and that means we have an
update for far cry 5 live events Rob
yeah live events oh these are rare he
owes me we're recording a video with her
in the middle of something live events
yeah that's been teased in the online
menu here and it opened up I think this
is the first one it's mauled well done
so I didn't know much about this until
now and looking at this menu but yeah
live events it's a kind of like a timed
challenge so you see there on top right
6 days and 20 hours to complete this my
personal progression is 6 animals killed
without using maltose or flamethrowers
you got to light them on fire not using
those two so you got to be using your
environment looks like half way I get a
I'm not quite sure how many but in
silver dollars oh can I go transaction
currency there and then the end game for
personal progression will be a new
flamethrower and if the community can do
it in time looks like an outfit flame
bread cool flame bear outfit got my I
wonder that outfit has any like special
properties do other ones have special I
have no idea I don't think so
other than just looking cool right so
anyways I've been playing so you know ok
obviously flamethrower and multiple
cocktails aren't ideal sure I did notice
here that this field has been has been
clutch go got him peaches but what's
funny is I was looking at my weapons and
like I was messed around earlier I
killed it
eight of these animals and has an
incendiary shotgun ammo but I made the
mistake apparently of not getting the
perk black market where I can buy more
incendiary ammo
so I had what I guess found them in the
world I don't know how else I got them
but that's fine so if you have that perk
this will probably be pretty easy then
yeah or it will help you Oh peaches no
we got a crowd I mean I guess the moat
so they here's the thing can I just do
this oh yeah yeah yeah that works right
peaches get out of here I feel like you
don't maybe you don't want a sidekick
peaches oh god I feel like he did that
did he how she's fine to about work yeah
that's the question the peak the
question is did penis peaches kill them
first
this whole place that's my favorite
thing about far cry since - is the the
fire tech yeah his fits are feeling good
oh no it's kind of messed up this is
quite quite the live event opening is
this like ad you're saying animals on
fire happy P today
oh they run yeah I'm not comfortable
necessarily doing this too bad do any so
it doesn't pop up a thing you know
unfortunate it is a little bit no that's
not working so maybe I'll just stick to
the environment or maybe it's gotta be
there's gotta be hostile animals or no
arctic housework yeah was a mid thought
there as the world is burning that's a
good point okay we got ourselves a
showdown oh there you go a bear in a
bowl perfect okay one of these should
work your perk that makes you run faster
what makes you move faster walk around
so technically oh that's a thumbnail no
technically if if it doesn't work that I
like if it's pure environmental I didn't
get the bear the bear was Splash Damage
so that should work I feel like at least
we'll get one
oh that's civilian kind of bliss spazzes
all right that's gotta be one come on
what kill as many animals as you can
with fire without using most of
cocktails or flamethrowers I'll light
them up and get cream do you think
because the fires on the ground it is no
longer your phone well that works it's
you know it is okay so that makes sense
because I was messing around earlier oh
it's just a that's a bummer it's just a
slow progression cuz I guess it has to
connect to the ubisoft servers oh is
that what that refresh thing means next
refresh when you're in absolutely right
oh that's kind of weird
that is weird so you don't really know
you don't really know till so we just
got to keep setting things on fire
keep going all right let's do it so
we're probably even at like four now I
wonder
oh that farmers gotta be pissed destroy
this feel I think justice field going up
in flames but there's always just a
freakin war
fire fight what are you shooting it oh
he's shooting at the photo farmer I
think like yeah like drill but then that
farmers just like me has a good time you
guys think you could spend these things
around the other way okay
you had an explosive arrow please help
me so that's kind of hard to tell right
like I would think yes I mean they only
the only limitations from altough and a
flamethrower so sure well it might kill
it
the explosion I killed what about like
next to it I'm gonna say no okay I feel
like the best tactic really is just a
repair torch it really is pretty good
get back here no he does not want
anything to do with peaches he knows
he's just so good peaches good
what if you like peaches on fire and
then a peaches attack that is dark is
dark below okay
[Laughter]
craziest ball God dang it
well maybe I get peaches
SiC and slow them down but you've been
lately it's been always dark for me yes
I don't know what it is I don't think
there's a way to change the time of day
and this one which three and four had so
I hmm
I know it slightly frustrated kind of
frustrating cuz this world looks far
Peach's far better in daylight although
I guess for for this video purposes feed
the fire will look nice and bright
I might as well give up on this bowl Oh
No
oh geez there is really no way to do
this oh there it is about getting
yourself on fire Thanksgiving dinner
[Laughter]
doesn't seem that concerned laughing oh
[Applause]
no look it he's still going he lasted
longer than the cow yeah turkeys are
pretty strong all right doesn't like
change the the type of meat you get
you'll get like cooked me or like burnt
me or something in the game in the game
I want to say changes the oh I thought
you just get feathers out of them
no because oh yeah but there's also like
meat you can get from throwing as bait
and I want to say sometimes it's like
cooked up hmm well for another minute I
mean I feel like we just had a minute
but ya know that definitely be said
well that's kind of that's kind of
frustrating tricked yeah
[Music]
oh no what's he doing here that guy's
also oh he's still there he's there
does he a lot yeah he's he's a gonner
he's he's shimmering I should press the
aah damn it oh you're right you're right
oh those beehives are gonna get on fire
is that I know that counts
they're not animals
yeah Oh get that I never been skunked
before my poison yeah you get hit there
what it does yeah I think it slowly
drains her hell yeah yeah I came across
some woman who just like all these
cultists were shooting at her and then a
skunk showed up and she's like get that
thing away
[Laughter]
they're like the sheer like audio or
like levels and and panic from people's
voices in this game just so gratifying
yeah just like the vo is always so
extreme I really got to turn around
all right yeah I mean I think this is
such a good area it's like a guarantee
there's gonna be open areas yeah do the
cows respawn pretty quick I am pretty
sure they do well no that was not me
ended down to that sit up here again
yeah
oh you know there's definitely gonna be
like a local news report like crazy
deputy that's animal so [ __ ] with
Jairo maniac Debbie nice creme brulee
yeah I want to say it resets oh well you
saw that tip that was like a UFO yeah
was friggin a helicopter
no there's no there's K over there what
about fish meets that fish on fire
probably not probably a man who you
probably remove them I don't even drop
them
[Music]
I wish you could like have like a like a
drum of oil you could just like yeah I
know awesome I want to like create a
trail that I light on fire totally that
that would be truly getting creative
[Applause]
they catch real quick to air smothered
in oil I mean I'm hoping wolf
[Applause]
I don't like this all the sound I don't
like any of this
these hassles testing their guns they're
missing so hardcore like look at they're
not even hitting that barn also dude
maybe should get out of the way Oh big
ol pegs yeah get those pigs coming Oh
[Applause]
bacon I don't like this this is quite oh
I think you got to the halfway okay so
it does tell you that that's nice yeah
that is nice so you're not burning
animals all day 30 animals and 50 silver
50 silver which is a 50 cents worth
because it is a it's like a dollar to
every 100 silver convert right right and
so that's the half the half way is 15
okay so you got nine more I want to see
what this flamethrower looks like
if you can run them over and squeeze oh
yeah
but again that farmers just doing this
thing they're shootin God yeah farming I
feel like oh yeah also this farming
technique is real oh I was he gonna go
after them
oh yeah he like what do they do that
every time they catch on fire they
always like run at those guys yeah sweet
well let's learn my friend I love that
quick the beer just guaranteed to show
up oh yeah it's ridiculous how quickly
they show up No
oh he put out the fire Denis now I'm
Bart oh no man you're in trouble
there is burnt meat I mean we could just
do this all day keep throwing it into
the fire
oh no animals seem interest in the bait
I think it's just to kill the bear no
animal seem interested in bait or the
fire here we go this guy's in oh he's
going after Oh No
there's another bear they killed that
guy bear bite Oh quick no no we have to
watch I know I gotta get up this guy
quickly but they fighting oh my god Rob
please like show that with the
binoculars
[Music]
oh dude you better get alright that was
pretty good I was pretty good people out
today
ah it's kind of late oh that was a
grenade I meant that piece oh I thought
I'd wear meet rats my god sorry dude Oh
was that what's up a bird Oh Dan
goes out pretty quick
well he's running toward some people
yeah they always just immediately run
for the people oh my god oh my god Oh
perfect slow down
Oh keep it back our team even with your
speed thing on he's so fast so fast give
up no oh come on
aah get him oh there's a bear fight
perfect perfect
nice little triple get back here switch
to the Bears yeah
light them on fire right
oh we're not on personal life
he doesn't mean drawing a line in the
sand like don't get it anywhere near my
fire he's back he's gone - that's three
hopefully three that bear might have
killed out of the one yeah these guys
never gonna make sure it's real it's
real doused where'd he go he ran he ran
towards them oh he did they messed up
their party they're the fast
[Music]
hopper jr. oh there it is that's it I
think you did it well we'll let you live
all right let's see this gun please okay
it's gonna I'm gonna have to buy it yeah
it's gonna have to I think it's just an
unlock and like now I can I know it what
if he it would be in this section right
it would be
[Music]
go back to the back to the live service
page yeah good point
whoever it's got live events okay we had
to go and claim it now I claim all right
and yeah now let's let's go to a general
store okay
nope you got it cool awesome is it any
better stats nope about same okay so
it's just all cosmetic
oh that's solid gold it looks pretty
cool that doesn't cool oh yeah it's got
all this like embroidery detail free
paint so simply I didn't take too long
to uh nose in ticular to get it so yeah
that's the first of their live events
I'm kind of curious what the other ones
are yeah here's here's hoping for a I
don't know I'd like to see some weapons
with different stats I'm me too
something like this is like it's neat
but I don't know unless you're like a
completionist maybe this is something
weird like shoots blue fire or something
yeah oh yeah sky no skins can hold me
over for only a short amount of right
especially if you've already maybe more
arcade related updates could be
interesting yeah all right well cool
that's gonna do it for this first live
event I think you guys for watching John
Luke thanks for taking a look at worse
with me and for those of you watching do
come back to see what other live events
are happening down the road
[Music]